he just basically like I would find  myself playing the game and then she  would wake up and call me and I'll be  playing the game and then she would  complain about cheese day with the kids  and I'm just playing my game and not  paying attention to her  I'm not feeling heard by my husband in a  time where I I literally cannot turn to  anyone else I can't go to my friend's  house I can't really do anything and the  only person that I can count on her lean  lean on their shoulder is my husband  it's one of the things I do wrong video  games  on top of the distance and this  craziness going on right now what did  you eat there is some trust issues in my  relationship with Ronald due to lying  because of the gambling addiction we're  trying to get past it but all of this at  the same time it's just too much today  I've set up a video call with a marriage  counsellor for Ronald and I